en fait ce qu'elle veut c'est un
champignon qui arrive à dégager dur et
c'est un champion qui est digne s'il n'y
a pas suffisamment de un endroit dans
des oeuvres de bach et des ramifications
comme ça là pour aller plus égaux que
les autres numéros qu'elle semble qu'on
a besoin pour pouvoir se développer
c'est une croissance qui va dégager le
bois qui va attaquer la structure du
bâtiment va sûrement la structure va
perdre son intégrité
donc c'est quelque chose qui évidemment
comme on dit on parle de caen salles du
bâtiment parce qu'une fois que ça soit
pas qu'un bâtiment
absolument il faudra voir des mesures
d'un camion pour s'en débarrasser et
c'est ce qu'on voit ces plis cage de
voix sont déposés au sol le sol est
saturé en eau ce qui fait en sorte
qu'ils les cages de vaud va capter l'eau
lorsque le doigté incertaines nous ce
qu'on appelle un certain tôt le matin il
va permettre le développement des
microbes la magistrate dont on voit
qu'il ne voit complètement le pouvoir
non loin un nourrisson haut du boîtier